in this video we'll look at seven
different ways to deploy
a server side application i built this
api with node.js
and now i'm ready to share it with the
world but one does not simply deploy an
app to production
there's all kinds of different ways to
get the job done with trade-offs between
cost complexity and scalability
on the surface deployment seems like it
should be easy we just need a computer
to host the app which we connect to the
internet so it can handle requests from
all of our users
but resources are limited and that means
we need to synchronize many computers
all over the world
just to keep things running fast by the
end of this video you'll be able to
analyze the trade-offs like a cto to
choose the best deployment strategy for
your server side application
if you're new here like and subscribe
then let's jump right into it
first of all let's look at some of the
features in this node.js application
it requires node 16 which is the current
bleeding edge version and that means
wherever we deploy
needs to support that exact version of
node it provides a basic rest api built
with the express js framework nothing
too special
but we want these endpoints to have
extremely fast response times
one of the endpoints though creates a
websocket connection with the client
that means that the connection between
the client and server needs to stay
open for a long time that'll come into
play later because not every deployment
strategy
supports long-lived connections like
that now one other important feature of
this server
is that it's stateless that means it
doesn't store any persistent data in
memory or on the disk
that's needed between different http
requests anything related to the
application state would be stored in a
dedicated database
now to run this app on our local machine
we use the npm start command made
available in the package
json file now the question becomes how
do we do the same thing for a computer
that's accessible to the greater
internet the first option
is to use your own hardware you might
have an old pc laying around or maybe
you want to invest in your own server
rack or you can even use a 100
raspberry pi like i showed in this video
this was actually a common way to deploy
a web application 15
years ago because back in those days the
cloud didn't exist yet
almost every startup today will use the
cloud because it's convenient and
inexpensive but deploying to your own
hardware has some unique advantages
most importantly you own your
infrastructure it's not owned by a tech
company
like amazon or google who can sync you
at any moment if they don't like the cut
of your jip
but managing your own hardware is a
major pain not only do you need to think
about the server configuration itself
but you also have to worry about things
like electricity
air conditioning natural disasters and
things like that
if the electricity or internet goes out
then your website goes down another
challenge is that if you're an
individual working out of your garage
you'll need to request a static ip
address from your internet service
provider
if they don't give you one then you're
pretty much screwed now as your app
grows in popularity
the only way to scale is to buy more
computers and ideally those computers
are located
in different parts of the world which
means you'll also want an international
real estate portfolio
luckily there is an easier way to deploy
a node.js application and it's called
the cloud
i'm going to focus on google cloud
platform for this video but keep in mind
that there are many different cloud
providers out there
offering similar services one option for
deploying to the cloud
is to use compute engine to create a
virtual machine which is basically just
a computer in the cloud
that you pay for by the hour and every
customer on google cloud gets one free
micro instance per month so the cost to
get started in the cloud is way lower
than if you were to buy your own
physical hardware
after creating a new vm on compute
engine it'll take a few steps to get
your app deployed
first you'll need to ssh into it to
interact with the operating system
install your preferred node.js version
then clone your source code to the file
system from there you can start the
application
then go to the firewall settings and
open up port 8080 so it can be accessed
on the internet and now technically your
app is deployed but there are a lot of
things missing here for one you'll need
to reserve a static ip address
then update your dns settings to point a
custom domain to it in addition you'll
need to manage your own ssl certificate
to serve it over https and another
problem
is that it's not going to scale
automatically once the cpu and memory
has been fully utilized the app will
just stop working we could address that
by bringing in
nginx or setting up load balancers but
it's a lot of extra configuration work
that most people don't want to deal with
so the next option we'll look at
is the app engine standard environment
for node.js which is a platform as a
service
it makes it incredibly easy to get our
local node app to a production server
and the cloud fully manages the virtual
machines which means your app scales
automatically as more traffic comes in
all that manual configuration we had to
do in the virtual machine is unnecessary
in app engine
because it's pre-configured to scale
popular types of applications
first we install the google cloud sdk on
our local system
second we create an app.yaml file in the
root of the project
inside the file we specify the runtime
as node 14. we can also use this file to
customize the hosting behavior
and set limits on how the infrastructure
will scale then the third step is to use
the gcloud app deploy command which will
upload the local code to the cloud
then look for the npm start command in
the package json
to run the application then it provides
a url where the actual hosted app can be
accessed and notice how it's http secure
because google manages the ssl
certificate for you
in addition app engine provides task
queues cron jobs
login and a bunch of other tools that
you wouldn't have in a normal vm
it's also important to point out that
app engine is a persistent server which
means it's capable of handling long live
connections like websockets and it's way
easier to get your app online compared
to a regular vm
but here's the catch the reason it's
called the standard environment is
because you have no control
over the runtime itself that makes it
easier for google to scale
but if you have custom runtime
dependencies or a version of node that's
not supported then you won't be able to
use it on the free tier
now although app engine standard is free
initially it becomes more and more
expensive as you scale up
and there may be less expensive
serverless options as we'll see later
the next option though is the app engine
flexible environment the primary
difference
is that instead of a sandboxed
environment you have full control over
the environment with docker
that means you can install any version
of node.js that you'd like along with
any other low-level system dependencies
but at the same time the cloud will
still automatically scale those vms up
or down based on the incoming traffic
and again this is called a platform as a
service and is very similar to things
like heroku
or elastic bean stock on aws all you
have to do is change the runtime to flex
in the app.yaml file
then add a docker file to the root of
the project app engine will
automatically manage the docker image
and containers for you
but in some cases developers want more
control to orchestrate exactly how their
infrastructure scales
and that's where kubernetes comes in i
once heard a wise quote about kubernetes
that went something like you don't
[ __ ] need kubernetes
and i think that's true for the vast
majority of developers out there if you
remember earlier deploying to a regular
vm
requires a lot of configuration
kubernetes also requires a lot of
configuration
but provides a predictable framework for
scaling your infrastructure
it's popular for large teams who have
extreme demands on their infrastructure
apps like robinhood and pokemon go use
kubernetes behind the scenes
but if you're just deploying a little
side project then kubernetes is probably
way too expensive and complicated
but at the other end of the complexity
and cost spectrum we have
serverless functions just like the app
engine standard environment
cloud functions provide a set runtime
and allow you to deploy your code
without ever having to think about the
underlying infrastructure
in fact you can just copy and paste your
code directly into the ui to deploy it
the primary difference here compared to
something like app engine
is that our servers are ephemeral or
short-lived and that allows google to
bill us for the exact amount of
resources that we use instead of paying
a fixed monthly price for a server
we pay a tiny amount each time a
function is invoked in addition you can
trigger cloud functions based on many
different events that happen in the
cloud like when a record is updated in a
database or when a file is uploaded to a
storage bucket and that makes it much
easier to run background jobs compared
to other approaches cloud functions are
a very easy and inexpensive way to
deploy a node app but there are a few
caveats that you need to be aware of
in our case we have an endpoint that
needs to support websockets
however because cloud functions are
short-lived we can't really implement
web sockets in them
another issue you might run into is
something called the cold start time
when a function is first allocated in
the cloud it might take a little while
to get things set up and produce a very
high response time on the initial
request
another drawback is the fact that you
have no control over the runtime when
using a serverless function
but there's actually one more deployment
option we can use to get around this
limitation called cloud run
it works just like a serverless function
but instead of using a predefined
runtime you can customize it by
containerizing your application with
docker
allowing us to specify the bleeding edge
version of node.js
along with any other low-level
dependencies that we might need once
we're able to run this app with docker
we can then upload the image to the
container registry then use the image to
create a new cloud run deployment and
now we have all the benefits of
serverless like automatic scaling
and pay-as-you-go pricing while also
having a lot more control over the
underlying server and as an
added bonus we can set a minimum number
of instances to reduce the cold start
time
although that comes at a higher cost and
with that we have seven different ways
to deploy
a node.js application if you want to see
some of these deployment options in
action
consider becoming a pro member at
fireship io to get access to my full
courses thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one